now
if you don't have information that's
helpful to this case
then you wouldn't be a witness correct
objection culture speculation
sustained sustained next question
okay you know this you know this case is
being televised right i am aware that
there are cameras and so this gets you
your 15 minutes of fame objection your
honor argumentative
i can ask that question oh ruled
um
so i stand to gain nothing from this i'm
actually putting myself kind of in a
target of tmz a very litigious
organization
and i'm not seeking any 15 minutes here
though you may you're welcome to
speculate i could say the same thing by
taking amber hurt as a client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly i find that to be purely
logical thank you now are you aware that
mr depp's attorneys were well aware of
the tro that was going to be
presented on may 27th objection calls
for speculation were you aware of that
lack of foundation
overworld if you can answer it can you
restate the question were you aware that
mr depp's divorce attorneys were aware
that amber heard was going in to see the
tro on may 27th
i don't think i understand the question
i don't think so now
okay do you know
whether blair burke one of mr depp's
divorce attorneys has a very close had a
very close relationship with tmz at that
time objection calls for speculation
overruled
if he knows
i was not aware of that okay and
when you said that you were dispatched
twice once to film amber for in the
parking lot for the deposition and then
it didn't work out and so you had to do
it another time how did you know it
didn't work out because tmz.com posted
an article saying as much okay i was not
dispatched do you know why the
deposition did not work out i'd have to
reference the article i forget so so do
you i i didn't write that story i wasn't
involved in the actual naturalism which
side
do you know which side would have known
or not known whether that deposition was
going to work out in other words the
people representing mr depp or the
people representing him has heard i
wouldn't know